why is there uh cream cheese this is
actually fantastic many a day I have
smoked something and then gone and
looked at the the cream cheese the next
day in the refrigerator and I'm like
it's covered in Orange residue I'm like
who would do what who did this what kind
of monster would do
[Music]
this what's up I'm Patrick and I'm Pete
and we're in a band called Fallout and
we're here to do snack Wars UK versus us
for lad
Bible
oh this looks fun it's a red velvet cake
right Y and I will give you a tener if
you can guess the name of the other one
no
dollops they look it they're actually
called spotted dicks this is spotted
dick I've spotted dick okay cool see
I've never had spotted dick um let's
see very tough doesn't want
to I like
that it's
great kind of a little warm still
somebody somebody worked on there
somebody loving it some worked on you do
things by half se you know I like that
would you have a spot dick again yeah
definitely yeah oh two at the same
time
um well I mean so I don't really love
the um uh the red velvet cake part
that's just a just a personal thing but
that frosting is I mean it's there's a
subtlety in this that you wouldn't find
because of the name you wouldn't think
of because of the name I liked it a lot
yeah I like that a lot I'm going to pick
this by I agree wow Spott a dick for the
win dick for the win boys right
dick all right oh we got a poke ball and
what is it eels jelly eels I thought
that was a joke are you kidding me I I
there was a I I do uh I do film and TV
scoring and there was a character who
eats jellied eels and something and I
genuinely thought that was a madeup
food there's no way this is a snack
people see what we got here no no no no
let's do this one first are you going to
do oh oh the scary Poke Ball that I had
for
lunch
yeah no all
right T like a usual for you back at
home yeah delicious is kind of standard
for me um but this this is this is what
we're here for right Bradley's trademark
just in case you you bought an off brand
one of
these
Bradley oh my God that is there's not a
lot of I would I expected it to smell
fishier that's not that fishy a
smell it's fine you know what this is
this is like um you're going to love
this by the way um I feel like I feel
like when I'm on um yeah I I go small we
got a lot of snacks to try here man I
don't know um don't fill up don't fill
up on eel
um you know what it tastes like a like
and this is obvious but a a like if you
if someone got a a Dragon Roll and was
like none of the stuff
please this is yeah honestly the worst
to me was the jelly part I don't really
want the I don't really want the jelly I
I would eat the eel like I'd eat the eel
as it eel great you seem pretty proud of
Bradley and his eels yeah so who are we
giving the point to here um oh goodness
cuz I eat this regularly I'm going to
have poke every I'm going to I'm going
to have a lot of poke but uh you know
know just hey when in Rome hey Bradley
good job you did it get my
vote I think this might be the breakup
of the band over wait are you serious
there's no way we both tasted both these
things there's no way you picked that
all right I'll go with whatever he says
Hey there you go we'll take that you
can't buy publicity like
that all
right pork crack that's all you man' oh
why is there uh cream cheese here oh
this is actually fantastic the hot the
hot Cheetos in the cream
cheese many a day I
have
smoked something and just and then and
then kind of forgotten I did it and then
G on and looked at the the cream cheese
the next day in the refrigerator and I'm
like it's covered in Orange residue I'm
like who would do what who did this what
kind of monster would do this
uh
okay am I doing this one yeah I don't do
Pork Man okay you can smell it I will
smell it
yes I I'll smell the
back it's like smells like vinegar but
it just tastes like rind or whatever
this is a good snack for when you're in
the pub like this is you have to be
several beers deep as well to have yes I
would agree I've have never done that
but this it's with no beers it is no
beers not a lot of pig and Magic
slightly limited Patrick this one's
fantastic I've never done this this may
be a post show one for you I don't know
Jesus I know what these
feel um I've never done this though the
uh you're going to be okay I'll walk I
know I'm really scared I'll walk you
through it I don't know cuz bring back
the
eel all right I love how you said don't
done this before as if anyone else has
done this I I I'm saying like is that a
thing is this a where did this come if
if someone so has anyone done this
before is this a standard only you have
done this before is that really true
yeah it's fantastic that is great I
swear to God it's fantastic everyone
should try it everyone here that is Paul
some around let's go that is excellent
that is UN that has no business being
that good I've never seen Joy like
this it's it's half shock people are
actually fighting their way to get into
this it's a TR it's a fair bit uh
surprise I'm I'm impressed that was as
if they were made to be pretty good
right like okay all right that was
delicious I don't I'm I'm I'm
shocked we I put that one in as a joke I
was like there's no way this is winning
I I thought that was a joke and by the
way it is I hate to say it it is so much
better than the than them by themselves
yeah no no no it's so much
than well I second
that have you tried pork crackling in
cream cheese all I'm going to do it I
I'll do it for
[Music]
science flavor profile doesn't work
quite as
well it's all right though
all right what we got
here dip dab I'm not familiar with
either of these things so I'm not sure
which one is the American one oh this is
the American one yeah yeah I've heard of
dip dab or dip dab dip dab what is it
it's like a oh there's like a stick okay
open it let's have a
go okay so it's a what's the we got
something like this right there's um uh
but RS is like a uh you eat the stick
right
that's
great that's
fantastic I feel like I'm going to go to
a
diabetic I don't know you know there a
lot oh this is going to be tough man
this is like a warhead all right let's
do this you feeling the F
yet I don't I fear no
[Music]
food
I mean it's not a pleasant sour it's
pretty freaking sour it's it's pretty
aggressive
um no we're going down with this
I'm all I'm all in consuming more I got
the good bit time oh all the sour is
gone and now it's quite
delicious I got through it that was that
was wonderful what was that about
consuming more than one piece what is it
about may cause irritation to the
mouth sensitive individuals should not
consume this project project that would
be me I'm I'm sensitive apparently
not but who gets the win on this one oh
I would fully give it to the UK I'm
giving it to dip daab that was better
that was that was quite nice and that
means the UK
one a very UK Clan well done I believe
Logan Paul's big fan of the
Prime I have noticed Logan holding
primes a lot I've not noticed Logan
drinking primes a lot I don't know just
when I'm looking but that has been
something that I have noticed